the University of Cambridge but
regrettably in my view not its colleges
has announced a two-year inquiry into
its historical links to the slave trade
and colonial exploitation that will
explore whether it should pay
reparations st. John's College Oxford is
following suit meanwhile the chairman of
the governor's at the University of East
London has called for universities that
benefited from the slave trade to
contribute to a 100 million pound fund
to support ethnic minority students now
I know some people will bury their heads
in their hands at hearing such news
perhaps even decrying this as yet
another example of political correctness
gone mad but surely one of the best
aspects of Nelson Mandela's legacy was
his shift away from criminalizing past
misdeeds but instead focusing on civic
processes such as the Truth and
Reconciliation committee
this was about allowing the truth to
come out and for information about the
past to become accessible to all a
University's purpose shortly is to
discover knowledge with that in mind I
don't see what harm researching and then
publishing the historical record can do
unless of course we can't handle the
truth okay I just have to think about
what I'm gonna say okay so this I think
this audit is shameful it's a historical
witch-hunt by a bunch of
self-flagellating self-aggrandizing
narcissistic people who want to form
their right on 10 cc's this Cambridge
University when a Brit didn't invent
slavery we didn't do it so it happened
it's been around since biblical times
and and we can't apologize for something
that we didn't do its history let me let
me make my point
Cambridge University already knows the
answer to did they participate so of
course they did because every major that
was that was the point of slavery as
disgusting as it was every major
institution profited from it and to do
all this is because this is a bunch of
people who just want to flaunt their
credentials the way it's Western people
standing on a platform and saying Mia
culpa website
you apologize for something you didn't
do for people who committed let me
finish for people who who committed deed
you didn't know when ozzie Prime
Minister John Howard was asked if the
Australians should apologize for their
the wrongs / Pathan perpetrated on the
Aboriginal people he said today's
generation cannot be held responsible
for people from the from the past and
that is absolutely sure
apologies mean nothing okay I'm not so
sure I asked for an apology but Nick
please practical terms all right I'll
tell you what it will be about I had
visited and I'll give this analogy
because it's a closest thing though not
it not the equivalent the Holocaust I
visited the Holocaust Memorial in Yad
Vashem and I have seen the names the
artifacts of everybody that was murdered
victimized and brutalized during the
Nazi Holocaust and it was incredibly
moving and educational for me now six
million Jews there abouts died at the
Holocaust with slavery of course it
wasn't six million in one go but there's
a damage that has been lasting 1 million
up to died on the transportation alone
and so I would like the truth and the
information to be available as an
educational project I don't see the harm
in that I haven't asked for an apology
I haven't said reparations need to be
paid what I would like is for the
information to exist what one point
unfortunately the job I do I've read
virtually every single newspaper
virtually every single death struck by
the letters to The Times and The
Telegraph one letter from dr. Alan
Chapman in Oxford pointed out and this
is what I think Cambridge University
instead of spending two years with I
think two people and an advisory board
of eight and what's that gonna cost you
will know and not be weary around this
table probly knows of course that it was
William Wilberforce along with Thomas
Clarkson who brought about the end of
slavery right to people to be applauded
which University of they attend right
the University of Cambridge
why is Katie why is it Cambridge
heralding the fact well but it was
people from our university who helped
bring about the end of slavery that's
what I would that's innocent can I just
say very quickly I I gave our team a
very quickly I gave an analogy
relating to remembering the victims I'm
I'm interested in curious as to why you
very quickly pivoted from me talking
about victims and I'm sure you'd agree
that slaves were victims
to talking about people but to talking
about hold on to talking about people
that weren't victims for people who had
the privilege the wealth the education
and the standing to do something about
slavery without being whipped on the
battery I want to be junior first of all
Majid and I said this to Karin when
Karen did a similar topic a few weeks
ago thank you for choosing this topic
because I think these conversations are
so important when you talk about guild
fests and self-flagellation this is not
what this is do if you look at let me
finish if you look at many of the
problems that we have in our society
around inequality if you look at many of
the problems that we have in our society
regarding race relations they stem from
the slave trade they stem from that
horrific period in our history in our
combined history whether you're from a
colonial country or whether you are from
the United kinderman and other Western
countries and I think that if people
really understood this history if they
really understood the sacrifices that
people from these countries made for
Britain to be what it is and to look at
how Britain benefited from this period
of history the way you view the other as
it were would be incredibly different
and this is why you'll put it's not
about reparations it's about accepting
wrongdoing and also acknowledging how
you have benefited well I'm probably
very similar to you I like going to
places I like reading and I like
learning especially about things that
I'm not massively affair with you know
in growing up or or haven't experienced
and I'm all in favor of investigations
for educational purposes so anything
that's going to help people understand
learn amplifies all the rest of it no
problem I'm very uncomfortable and this
isn't what you're suggesting but the
next point I'm very uncomfortable with
people doing investigations in order to
like guilt fest or all the rest of it
because yeah we can't look his you know
hip slavery was a massive and is a
massive stain on our history
and we can't feeling the effects of it
why we comment at the history yeah so
I'm in favor of what you're saying which
is going backwards for educational
purposes but I'm also very sympathetic
to what Nick's saying which is we
shouldn't be going backwards in order to
force apologies or guilt fest of it
because it's just you can't judge
history by more than one thing please
one thing this isn't about going
backwards if you're still feeling that
the the issues and you're still feeling
the effects of something that was done
in the past whatever that's personally
or if we're looking at historic in a
historical context until you acknowledge
that and you look at why it's impacting
you today
nothing contingent I'm seeing this as an
educational endeavor I currently do not
see a museum to slavery in the United
Kingdom both II we were one of the
largest participants in the I seek to
ask for truth and reconciliation we
can't simultaneously to my mind applaud
people like Nelson Mandela who took this
view and took its approach a methodology
and at the same time visit Holocaust
memorials and applaud their existence
because we want to remember the past of
atrocities committed no one accuses
those are being guilt fests slavery was
on on that civilizational scale of an
atrocity I'm yet to see any museums I
mean I want to see the boots of the
slave children that were taken away what
you say but how nervous are you that as
part of this inquiry at Cambridge
they're also going to look in past
teaching practices by professors and
Don's who are no longer here to defend
themselves like some very eminent people
who might be effectively labeled racist
or perpetuating racist myths and these
men or Makani the defendants are that's
wrong an answer and I'm known to
challenge the excesses of the left and I
get a lot of flack for it they I think
it was Oxford or Cambridge forgive me
one of the colleges have recently sacked
a professor because they've accused him
of looking into race and racial
differences from a scientifically no I
don't agree that's why we pull the
brakes in that's not a reason to do can
I just bring up a stance this is why
that's one minute this is why this is so
important okay so this is from the
National Archives
it says Britain was the most dominant
between 1640 and 1807 when the British
slave trade was a bond
it is estimated that Britain transported
3.1 million Africans of whom 2.7 million
of rice or million or almost a million
of them died to the British colonies in
the Caribbean North and South America
and to other countries the slave trade
was carried out from many British ports
but the three most important ports were
London Bristol Liverpool which became
extremely wealthy Liverpool we're not
going backwards we are now going
forwards coming up here on the place
[Music]